[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24 ya está conmigo en el estudio
rosa pérez masdéu masdéu rosa bienvenida
vamos a abrir entonces esta revista de
prensa con una situación en reino unido
tras la moción de censura boris johnson
que el primer ministro acabó superando
por 211 votos a favor de su permanencia
ya me estoy frente a los 148 cv votaron
en su contra veamos entonces como lo
aborda primero la prensa internacional
buenos dias raúl y es que aquí en esta
sección no bueno y en nuestros
noticieros hemos dedicado muchos minutos
a está prácticamente telenovela por
distintos episodios del partido y quién
sabe si tras la votación de ayer ya
estamos ante una clausura no de toda
esta trama pero por lo que apuntan los
medios internacionales y también los
británicos que luego veremos más bien no
parece que esto vaya a terminar pronto
no porque un poco el resumen de muchos
de los titulares y adjetivos que se
dedican a boris johnson es que la
victoria al margen de victoria en esta
votación está demasiado estrés como para
que puedas seguir gobernando
tranquilamente no empecemos por el wall
street journal que dice johnson
sobrevive a la revuelta pero anda herido
como decíamos herido y debilitado son
dos adjetivos que encontraremos muy
repetidos en los titulares dice por un
lado que la propia organización de esta
moción de censura refleja el nerviosismo
interno dentro del partido conservador
por el hecho de que la figura de boris
johnson y sobre todo su implicación en
este partido pues ponga en peligro la
continuidad del partido al frente del
ejecutivo británico y sobre todo de cara
a las próximas elecciones generales que
reino unido tiene que celebrar antes de
enero de 2025 y por otro lado dice que
el resultado de la elección no está
victoria aunque estrecha pues victoria
de boris johnson que le permite
continuar al frente del partido y
también pues del ejecutivo británico
pues reflejan que no hay un reemplazo
claro pues para el actual primer
ministro y por otro lado bueno vamos a
la frankfurter allgemeine este medio
alemán que dice la red lyon tory fracasa
con la moción de censura contra johnson
pues un poco en ese mismo sentido el
este medio alemán apunta más pues a la
derrota de la rebelión la vanguardia
también dice johnson salva el voto de
censura pero sale debilitado como
decíamos pues esta debilidad con la que
cuenta ahora el primer ministro se
repite en muchos de los adjetivos que se
le atribuyan y público de portugal dice
boris johnson sobrevive en un partido
conservador dividido por la mitad que
dice entonces ahora la prensa reino
unido luego haber visto los
internacionales desde la prensa del
reino unido hoy sí que pues
prácticamente en su totalidad
contacto lleva pues este tema en sus
portadas empezamos por the times que
dice un vencedor herido dice johnson
declara una victoria decisiva pero el
resultado es peor de lo esperado y
encontramos también en the times una
comparación que hacen muchos medios de
comunicación y es que comparan la
situación de boris johnson con lo que
acabó sucediendo tanto a margaret
thatcher como a teresa male y es que
ambas se enfrentaron a mociones de
confianza en él de su propio partido
también ambas las acabaron superando con
estrechas victorias pero finalmente
fueron también ambas primeras ministras
forzadas un poco por su propio partido a
renunciar también muchos medios destacan
que digamos la oposición a boris johnson
es mayor que la oposición que tuvieron
en su momento thatcher email pero la
verdad es que los números son muy
parecidos no johnson ha contado con un
41% de oposición mientras que margaret
thatcher en 1990 días antes también de
renunciar con todo con un 40.9 de
oposición y teresa me cerca al 37%
también encontramos en the times un
matiz digamos que puede ser importante
por lo que decíamos el futuro de esta
trama porque ahora por ahora en
principio el partido conservador no
podría volver a someter a boris johnson
a una moción de confianza hasta de aquí
un año sin embargo el reglamento interno
puede cambiar y puede ser que pues se
vuelve a someter a boris johnson a este
tipo de votación dentro de seis meses
vamos a ver también los opinadores de
the times hablan de un muerto andante y
lo que decíamos que el rechazo es
demasiado amplio para que sobreviva y
que el actual primer ministro debería
cómo buscar una salida elegante por otro
lado the gardian dice el primer ministro
se aferra al poder tras un voto de
humillación no y éste se aferra al poder
también lo encontramos mucho y dice que
mantiene la mayoría solo pues por 63
votos digamos de diferencia y dice the
gardian que incluso algunos de sus
defensores defensores consideran que
esto es el principio del fin de los tres
años de johnson al frente del número
días no el número 10 de downing street
es pues la sede del gobierno británico y
también la sede de estas fiestas
enmarcadas en este ya escándalo conocido
como el partido por otro lado the daily
telegraph dice estrecha victoria divide
a los tories la autoridades se queda
pues aplastada del general dice herido y
debilitado pero johnson promete
permanecer en el cargo y adelanta este
medio que es eso si el partido
conservador dividido podría
frente a un bloqueo en el parlamento
recordemos también que la cámara baja
está investigando el partido por su
cuenta pero señala que del general que
el partido no es el único problema que
enfrenta a johnson o que también digamos
a su política tributaria no hay derecho
de bajar de subir perdón a los impuestos
pues está enfadando a algunos miembros
de su partido y terminamos con los
tabloides 7 parece ravasi es de rosa
vamos a ver entonces qué dicen los
tabloides sobre qué pues es que los
tabloides como bien comentamos aquí a
menudo a veces tienen titulares un poco
esperpénticos o al menos de un gusto
ciertamente dudoso por ejemplo the sun
titula la noche de los cuchillos rubios
y aquí hace un juego de palabras entre
el long de largos y blond de rubios como
el primer ministro no y es que pues hace
referencia a la noche de los cuchillos
largos no en 1934 en el seno puede ser
del partido nazi y esa purga de las s/a
y dice apuñalado
148 veces por la espalda metro dice la
fiesta se acabó
es una política habla de un político
pues agonizante mientras que el daily
star dice el mentiroso sobrevive para
mentir un día más sigue adelante pinocho
gracias.rosa como siempre por toda la
información de revista de prensa nos
vemos mañana con más pasamos a saludar
precisamente para ampliar este tema a
nuestro primer invitado